douze aujourd'hui on se trouve sur
tablette pour jouer un jeu hors du
commun est d'avoir j'ai découvert cette
application c'est parti s'appelle
facebook live et on peut en fait tout
simplement devenir un pb franchement vu
des miracles avec cette application
comment je ferais trouvé l'ambiance est
là
donald trump salut je suis un gros fils
de [ __ ] y autour des excuses aujourd'hui
je voulais être un peu plus tard que
d'habitude un peu plus viril a cédé
[ __ ] ça défend monde ou quoi c'est moi
quand je reviens quand je suis un petit
youtuber retraite troyenne en plus j'ai
un début de ride comme ce mec donc je
suis très peu rassuré au haut
je suis extrêmement fort musique
classique mama ohoua bonjour je suis
très efficace et très copines copine
avec hollande
il aime beaucoup mon physique je suis
marilyn monroe mais vraiment beaucoup
moins belle à tort et âme du style ça
c'est mais ça c'est la vraie c'est la
vraie marée humain non là je suis un
clown beach puis tué sa mère au lieu de
chialer petit chat mais de telles images
sont déjà extrêmement rigolos ou alors
juste à l'arrière au revoir un bonhomme
de neige nuls attendue elle est nulle
salut tout le monde
c'est lucas et c'est un peu chelou comme
visage de big ben arous belles
trouvailles à wayne on met le gab ces
petits jeux de poissons monga bouge tout
le temps blasé j'en ai un peu marre de
des vidéos là alors il est pire que tout
oui c'est vrai ya l'option masse si vous
n'êtes jamais le visage de quelqu'un sur
moi celle inverse quoi attend ça pas
trop bien
attends abonnez vous chez l'oréal
abonnez vous oh mon dieu c'est quoi ça
bordel au mont-gabriel m'a fait de la
chirurgie mais que tout a raté je suis à
bramois ça normal bonjour je suis la
joconde la vraie tuerie alwan
je suis barack obama autant s'amuser da
ou de mec à moi que c'est moi qu'on
trouverait là ça marche super bien ce
truc de fou
ces expressions du visage changeant les
autres les miennes et si les gars de
narines elles sont des bouge toi ça
marche trop bien mon gars je suis donald
trump aux mecs c'est chaud
faut dire un hacker connu 14 une photo
de cet acteur juste là voilà c'est
exactement le même visage
attention une marilyn monroe comme ça
bonsoir les darling j'ai un petit grain
de beauté juste ici au la mecque
franchement je préfère ne pas être viril
et pas trop avoir cette tête j'avais
capacité de retirer mon visage michael
bay a besoin de mes effets spéciaux
contactez moi et alors maintenant
attention c'est là que ça n'a plus prend
tout son intérêt on va plus monsieur
mika qui va venir dans deux secondes et
on va prendre l'option la plus drôle de
la planète sur 7 après vous allez voir
c'est fantastique ça fait des miracles
nous avait un rhume vous lancer ce tapis
vous allez être guéri bonjour mes
cadeaux carmen tanner psychopathe quoi
n'importe quoi alors savard suis très
bien au début oui ça c'est le futur
nationale non mais bouge la tête farcie
à des notions swype la faim et soif live
j'ai un peu raté bon ça va mais c'était
pas les laver au savon appelons cette
entrée dans une prochaine
et franchement pour moi c'est l'une des
meilleures applis que j'ai pu
télécharger c'est vraiment hyper drôle
cette vidéo avec john un chef-d'oeuvre
en témoigne ce autour du tout le monde
sait ce coup ci
mesa marauder versini cas d'être passé
pour vraiment 38 ans de vidéos
ça me fait super plaisir tu peux rentrer
chez toi ton chaque et sur la commode
c'est faux il ya pas de chèque à part ou
une tarte au citron à savoir dire stop
et la semaine prochaine vidéo portez
vous bien chaude pisse